csis unit 37 Toronto is under attack
null sector
something
about no sector this time
they've taken over most of the city and
they're rounding up omnics they need our
help
people are answering Vincent's recalls
and we have so much to teach them
stop null sector maybe we can save the
city coming through
it's been a while as if I didn't have
enough problems already
smash through anything that gets in our
way
and what's another business I hate to
interrupt the moment but I'm picking up
reports of more attacks in other cities
it's a fight day one I say let's give it
to them
oh
[Music]
Target
time to create peace
[Music]
the world is coating on us